pain is pain and hurt is hurt and loss
is losses loss is loss
right and yeah trying to compare it or
say mine's worse or mine's more noble or
mindset
man loss is loss is lost
who's witnessing this with you grief
demands a witness
that people grieve together and i think
that's one of the great curses of our
time who's with you on this
journey you're on
you know
i am so fortunate um to be
surrounded by so many friends
and family members and even
acquaintances
past co-workers people i haven't heard
from in years have caught wind of this
and
you know i'd like to think that being
there for people
what goes around comes around good or
bad and it pays interest
and i've had friends show up at my door
that
they flew in from nashville they flew in
from sacramento
i've got friends in over you know in
england who have said as soon as these
borders open
i'm coming for you and tell people what
that means
to have that community because this is
not something you developed after this
happened
this is years and years of you being a
person
of like you said investing in
friendships and in community
relationships
not if but when something goes sideways
and
tell people what that feels like to have
people just showing up at your door
not saying anything bringing some crummy
food and just sitting with you or saying
i'll be there
like walk people through the feeling of
that
it's an it's an interesting feeling and
i will do my best to try to describe
it when
you do anything for the people that you
love
friends family strangers whoever
when i say jordan was a great stranger
a perfect stranger i think maybe
that was one of his best characteristics
and we have always said to each other
we have no idea what somebody else is
going through
to know that people caught wind of this
and dropped everything and just got on a
plane
or came over you know
nobody knows what to do right everybody
says tell me if you need anything
call me if you ever need anything truth
be told you have no idea what you need
because you're in the sick of it and i
probably feel him in some ways
but
[Laughter]
the chances of you even remembering this
call six months from now is pretty slim
but yeah you're for sure in the thick of
it yeah but to have that love and that
outpouring around you
not only for yourself but for your
spouse
it means a lot and it has taught me a
lot
about when other people i know in the
future may be experiencing
i hope that they never go through
anything like this but
other traumas and other difficult
situations
sometimes you might not know what to say
you don't want to call somebody when you
think they're having a good day what if
they start crying
they're gonna cry anyway so just show up
for them yeah
so um if you
could could be up on a stage in front of
a thousand
couples dating married on the brink of
divorce
figuring out you know 20 years in and
they're figuring out they still like
each other
if you could stand up there and give one
one piece of advice of wisdom to to
married couples
not that you know everything right um
you've only been married
like what a few years and but
you're standing up there on the other
side of a mountain that
many people will never climb what would
you tell them
you still have time
that's that's really it i mean there's
you know you still have the one thing
that i can't buy or make more of
and you've still got that that is such
an incredible
asset and resource to have but it's also
something that we take for granted
and if you're willing to put the work in
with each other
and invest your time in your marriage
and your relationship
in whatever you're struggling with
that's the hard part i've already done
we still have the opportunity
and i would give every last dime i ever
made in this lifetime
to have one more conversation
you've still got time that may be one of
the most profound
statements i've heard in several years
you've still got time
period but you don't know how much
that's right every second yeah
so um this is an unfair question i'm
going to ask you
and you can just say i don't know you
idiot
or you can just guess knowing that we'll
all be graceful for it with you
what's next for you like what does
tomorrow look like what's the next few
weeks look like for you what do you have
um circling around your heart and mind
today knowing that it's going to change
so jordan and i were
are both very big baseball fans and
people have said to me what do you need
what do you need tell me what you need
tell people when your fridge is full
because it'll just keep showing up
so that's one thing oh the western world
loves to eat
laura the thing that i that's next for
me
is um i started telling jordan's friends
and family
if you don't know what to do for me i'll
tell you this
come with me to a baseball game sit with
me at coors field here in denver
talk to me about jordan ask me questions
about jordan
or we can just sit there in silence have
a beer have a hot dog
and just watch a game and that closeness
that you could deal with somebody who
just
sits right next to you you don't even
have to say anything
that's priceless yeah
don't have to have in fact it's not only
do you not have to have the right things
to say
would you agree laura there is nothing
anybody can say
it's a matter of hey i'm gonna go get
another beer you want one right
absolutely you're you're spot on right
there and the thing is
is that sometimes the conversations that
have made me
feel so much better
are the people who have been up front
and have said to me laura
there are no words i'm just going to
tell you how really
insert choice word messed up
this is and i'm not going to say it was
jordan's time
i'm not going to say at least you got x
amount of months
oh jesus nobody say that ever
gee nobody say that because to be honest
i moved back to denver from australia
in 2019. i met jordan a few weeks later
one of the best things about my husband
is that when i shared with him early on
that
men in the past had called me a
commitment phobe or a flight risk he
grabbed my hand
and said where are we going
he was smooth dude that's a smooth line
right there i'll give him that one
you only knew that's a good lie and to
come back home to the us
and to be with somebody marry them
move in with them and to have lost them
all in less than
two years wow
they're out there don't settle and don't
give up because if i can experience that
i've just learned that if you're holding
on so tight to something you're afraid
to let go of
you don't want to be alone the lord or
the universe isn't going to put anything
in full hands
because there's no room for it
i love that so um
number one i just want i want to thank
you for being brave and for giving me a
call
and for telling your story here and for
inspiring people to be
positive people finding beauty even when
it's a mess
for teaching people you're modeling for
people how to talk about
really heavy trauma and really heavy
loss
and you man you gave me a few quotes
right
be a great stranger to people
and to remember you still have time
thank you so so much for sharing that
hey laura i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
this
um two things that i've seen um over the
last
i don't know decade of sitting with
folks in your exact situation
the the tendency
is to like you said start looking at
text messages and voice messages
and behaviors and things and trying to
re-pattern and recreate
the past i've never found somebody that
that brought them peace
and i've never found somebody that found
a dotted line that made them go oh okay
what the only thing i've ever seen
people find peace is
with how you're doing which is taking
crooked steps into the future
in an effort to honor this awesome
awesome guy
and the second thing is i want to
commend you for telling your story and i
hope you will continue to tell the story
and you mentioned something that i want
to make sure that you don't forget
you mention that you're the only one
that knows his secrets
and that there is a story to tell there
there's lives to be saved there there
are relationships to be mended there
but i also want you to remember that
you're the only one that knows your
secrets
and those are worthy of being told to
and you're a brave strong
brilliant woman and my day
is infinitely better my life is better
because you
took some time to tell your story and
i'm confident with 100 certainty that
the people listening to this
um have taken a moment to exhale
probably a breath they haven't exhaled
in years
and are grateful that you took that time
to be brave too
so thank you laura for telling your
story
thanks john i uh i really appreciate it
and um
if you're ever in denver your baseball
tickets on me
including june 20th for jordan's
celebration alive
i'm so grateful for that um when the
astros play i will be there
and they will probably cheat but they
will still win they will beat your
precious rockies right thank you so so
much laura
um to everybody listening i don't care
where you are
what you're working through what you're
struggling through you still have time
you're worth being well find somebody to
talk to find somebody to reach out to
find somebody that you love find
something that you don't know
that you want to get to know if your
relationships on life support you still
got time
you still got time